[Music]
foreign
well I'm about to watch a video
uh some scary movie
uh-huh
[Music]
oh
um I guess oh An Inconvenient Truth
oh that is a good one
why do you want to know my name
[Music]
listen ask
how do you know my name
who's the [ __ ] now
horror movies don't work with a Walther
your popcorn's burning [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen guess who gets to
sit back at this desk again and I even I
even have a sign
yeah nice sign that
rainbow colors
Stephen did did you get your voice back
no you [ __ ] oh wow that's that's
violent Brett's already at the start of
the show
look at me yeah yeah I'm looking at you
you've got this I do no you falling down
no you have throat cancer I don't I'm
I'm fine I can speak
[Music]
all right guys well thanks for joining
us we appreciate you obviously Steven is
going to be sitting in third chair for
us today
um having a little bit of uh you know
some stuff in your in your throat making
it a little bit more difficult for you
[Music]
no I don't think you're dying I mean
maybe one can help
[Music]
I don't think it's monkey I don't think
you want to declare that you have monkey
pox that's not something that you would
say maybe the sign is more fitting for
for you I did start this that's true the
show is off to a fantastic start so
thanks for joining us guys obviously
Steven already he's going to be here
he's going to be chiming in on a lot of
stuff today he can still talk his voice
is not gone
but Dave hi how are you sitting over in
my chair this time oh boy I'm good how
about you I am doing well so are you
ready for a good job center myself
trying to yeah well it's difficult
you've got the fisheye lens there
welcome to my world yeah I gotta try not
to look weird I'm there yeah I won't I'm
pretty seat height adjusted accordingly
yes I uh I put the seat up as high as it
could go and added a booster uh booster
yes the phone books is what we actually
put in there
ah this is gonna happen all show that's
my grandfather's Last Words yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
laughing at you than For You Stephen how
are you doing today I know you're
without that with I mean come on
[Music]
oh that's weird
all right
we got this for the Halloween
Spooktacular for next week which we
should probably announce uh yeah well
that's happened but I was like you know
what we have it we should use it yeah
well Monday so everybody's going to be
in costumes for Monday the Spooktacular
sometimes we've done those live in the
past we're not doing a live but we're
doing our normal live show here but it's
not going to be normal and that we'll
have costumes on I fear costumes when it
comes to this place because of things
like that we don't tell you what we're
the sign that is all rainbow colors
which you can guess it's a Christian
reference it just means that God
promised he wouldn't destroy the world
by water again but it was hijacked so
whatever that's what it's the
anyways
that's that was the true meaning behind
it
listen I'm gonna go with the original
meeting okay not the stolen one we're
gonna get to some fun stories today and
uh you know first off with San Francisco
they're spending a whole lot of money on
a toilet it's probably just going to be
crapped on the floor
um yes exactly until it was called San
Francisco uh it used to be Oakland
that's a fair point it's easy to confuse
they actually want you you to do the
defecation inside of a room now yeah
yeah so we'll see how that works out Ted
Cruz was on The View I think that
probably got a little bit spicy I don't
know why they would invite him they
don't like him hey I don't know hey do
you guys know this uh I don't Dave I
don't know if you're aware that uh Anna
Navarro she used to be a republican what
no no way how'd you find that out are
you serious well she let us know oh
every time she speaks yeah she has no
choice she goes to McDonald's to order
and I uh used to be a republican can I
get a McGriddle she has to no no it has
to contractually obligated yes yes to do
that for the video so that'll be fun I
see I see because that's really the only
Spanish yes
no
former
that's how their language works we love
you people who speak Spanish Dave is not
trying to insult you no um one thing we
haven't done and we're getting pretty
close to it the midterm elections are
coming up we're going to break that down
and give you all of the information that
you need to know there
um it's it's great Republicans are doing
very well despite what Democrats tried
to do throughout the month of September
and really leading up to the past couple
of weeks and then Mud Club we're going
to get into the media ignoring certain
Shooters and we've talked about this
before there seems to be a bit of a
double standard but before we get going
tell us what is your prediction this is
our question of the day what's your
prediction for the midterms uh for 2022
there's a lot of close races out there
there are a lot of people saying that
there was a bit of a Blue Wave or a blue
Resurgence coming the numbers are not
bearing that out and and maybe a little
sub question for you if that's possible
do you believe any of these polls
anymore that tell you that Democrats are
doing incredibly well how many times do
the polls have to be wrong before we
finally believe them yeah uh to be false
right right so I don't know let me know
what you think I do know this that's
actually a good point though that really
is a good point if you're using a
Diagnostics tool and it's always wrong
50 even if it's 50 of the time I know
it's it's no longer useful it really is
you have to say is this is this tool of
any use if it's designed to be a
predictor and it can predict yeah
exactly that's like 12 of them to screw
in a light bulb it does pulsers and
little white boards that they hold up
and they're wrong with the numbers
um but basically you just made the case
for weathermen not existing how many
antivirals does it take to screw in a
light bulb uh one and one to say it's
used to be Republican well thanks for
steaming
because I had 14 other Anna navarros but
same thing
they would all just say I'm a former
Republican and never actually get to
know for me not to know where you were
all right so Rebels with a cause tour uh
you guys are on tour and if you need
tickets go to loudwithcrowder.com tour
November 12th Raymond Auditorium just
the second show at the second show 30. I
think there might be I think we might
have released some I don't Dave do we
release comps in the first there might
be like 30 tickets in the first show but
they're singles yes I mean if you're if
you're feeling lucky try for the first
show yeah we release some comps but um
there's not yeah there's not much left
for the late either though so I'd get on
it yeah make it happen it's going to be
a fun time it's coming up pretty quickly
we can actually gloat because the
election will be done now in places like
Georgia they may not want to call it yet
maybe for a couple of weeks they enjoy
the spotlight or if you're Stacy Abrams
ever well yes we'll get to that that's a
little foreshadowing right now we also
mentioned the costume contest uh send us
your costume pictures uh post on
Instagram and remember to include your
mug if you have one if you don't have a
mug what in the world is wrong with you
these things are fantastic and girthy
and wonderful tag your pick with lwc
Spooktacular at louder with Crowder do
both all right you're gonna sound bite
that right yes
what did I do you said fantastic girthy
and what oh son of a gun that's all we
need Stephen said something that was
sound bitable early but we can't say it
it's not relevant he didn't say turkey
though
yeah
how's a mug throbbing though Gerald I
didn't say that part that was and I'm
not going to repeat it because that's a
problem he'll clip it mugs can't be
vascular Gerald do you see what I have
to do not only do I have to do the show
I have to dodge the attacks from these
fellows here and also the sound I could
literally get into an argument with
myself he has so many sounds why do you
want to have three mugs all over your
face yes
shrimp
that's true that's a fair that's a fair
all right that's a fair critique all
right look we're going to get into
something that uh is is interesting I
thought this was a bit turns out it's
not Katy Perry
um at a concert in Vegas this past
Saturday night had a uh I don't know
people are calling it The Pfizer eye you
be the judge
[Applause]
wait for it oh
oh no it fell again it looks like a
droopy-eyed armless child what do I do
[Music]
did you see that dude she's like a
button on her Temple she does like it's
cyclops's visor
I got it
so wear sunglasses if your eyes been a
twitching all day yes it closed
involuntarily the whole and then she had
to nobody's gonna notice this they're
not all looking at me but the the poses
she's the Ying to Justin Bieber's stroke
face Yang
they should go on tour together
that's one hell of a Face-Off poster you
can ring I'm gonna take your eyelid down
that's not a good thing no no look here
I'm just gonna let me just an example
she's very sick example right here all
right I'm posing for the camera
eye starts to close uncontrollably I
look I Look Away I turned the other way
and play it off as soon as she grabbed
the mic which by the way was awkwardly
placed yes I guess in the only place you
can hold a mic like that you got cans
all over your dress there's nothing you
can do there right she got cans under
her dress and well yeah yeah she starts
to walk away and talking to the mic and
it look it feels like the eyes back to
normal at that point why didn't you just
do that why did you stand there and let
everybody take pictures and video of you
that's why I thought it was a bit I'm
sure oh of course sure there's delayed
cognitive ability I'm sure it's not just
the eye so it's easier it's easy to
Monday Morning Quarterback it when you
didn't have a stroke yes and I wasn't on
stage at the time I get it and yeah mine
if you can feel it wouldn't you make the
other eye do the same thing just yeah
close them both yeah yeah yeah it's
supposed to just keep the one open and
be like nobody notices that this wonky
Forest Whitaker out of nowhere yeah
no she uh yeah she dabs it her one ear
is just gushing blood it's fine totally
fine guys by the way I'm gonna put that
here towards the camera yeah her ear
starts leaking like Westworld yeah yeah
she blocks it up yeah
let's pull the uh the one of the
funniest things I've ever seen we did
this years ago remember when she faced
plants into the fake cake that she
thought was real
on stage really I don't know yet I
kissed a girl and I liked it and they
clearly like didn't they she wasn't
planning on jumping in the cake or at
least the stage handlers it's a fake
cake yeah and she jumps face first and
her head just boom Oh that's hilarious
and then she she can't get off the stage
she tries to stand up but you know she's
on queer street so she tries to stand up
she falls and she's covered in frosting
and she tries to stand up again and she
falls she just she's so defeated and she
just crawled off stage yes it's like
it's a fake cake why would it be a real
cake we have to take it on tours
do you understand the logistics involved
with a cake this size on a bus doesn't
work very we're not all having cake yes
it's awesome
yeah we definitely have to see that we
can't be bulimic Katie oh that's true
well guys look
I've got some good news for you San
Francisco is cleaning up attacked
they're actually going to build uh
one toilet a new one right and there's
an insane price tag you might say a
hundred thousand dollars 200 1.7 million
dollars for a toilet and to get this
thing done it's going to take a little
bit of time and cutting some red tape
and it is absolutely insane here watch
them 11 are questions being raised over
the price tag of a public toilet in San
Francisco she's so surprised they are
now according to the chronicle the
single toilet costing the city one point
located near
24.'s Main commercial Corridor where you
find this porta potty right now
supervisors say they got the funding
from the state budget to build the
restroom per request of family in the
area in a joint statement issued to the
paper the Park and Recs Department of
Public Works says there are several
reasons for the cost that includes the
cost to build in the city
for materials the restroom won't be
completed until
2025. what wow that is these people want
to convert US to a high-speed rail yeah
that's just you need two and a half
years call it minus any construction
delays because we know this isn't going
to be a smooth process in San Francisco
to build a toilet just to see what
homeless person is going to Squad in it
oh my God squat beside it let's be
honest they've made up their mind no yes
exactly by the way just for comparison
the Empire State Building only took one
year and 45 days to build the Empire
State Building which included more than
one restroom yes in the building just to
be clear also had like a casualty rate
of 1900 with guys lunch boxes on beams
but we got a lot of really cool pictures
that we could put on the wall like where
guys are like sitting there like oh that
makes like a fun job when I see it it
makes me dizzy when it's up there on the
beam yeah it doesn't make me dizzy it
just makes me like that was stupid yes I
understand why our mortality it was high
way less people died making the uh
toilet fire State Building yeah
oh yeah yeah exactly they have to send
in a new construction worker a new
plumber because the next one comes out
looking like Hellraiser with just
syringes in his head it's not good
something again just being here I'm good
I got another syringe in my side what
happened to the plumber he I have so
much to show you yes oh boy this is
gonna be fun well look in Florida they
the uh you remember the bridge that got
knocked out by the hurricane uh
hurricane Ian they actually repaired
that in just a matter of weeks right so
repaired an entire Bridge they were
dumping Stone and sand in the ocean they
repaired a bridge you guys are going to
build a toilet in about two and a half
years and cost 1.7 the Porta John looked
like it was doing fine yeah okay I
understand they'd like a nicer place to
sit and squat but I don't think that's
really going to happen the entire city
is a toilet there's feces everywhere why
would you build a toilet well I think
what they were going for Dave and that's
a fair point is that they were trying to
be a little bit more like Portland's
toilets yeah but it's it's okay it's
communal that's that's for a single it's
for a single person oh right right yeah
that's true yeah you can't you can't
underestimate the communal aspect of
crapping in the streets and shooting up
fentanyl yes that's true is it is it
just for one guy yeah like only one guy
can use the toilet that's why it's a
single person I'm willing to bet that
one guy will claim the toilet as his
residence and not let anybody else use
it it's gonna claim [ __ ] gun yeah oh no
he got a one 1.7 million dollar house
that's exactly
I think with free Wi-Fi it's a public
space
squatters rights do apply if you haven't
noticed already this is a live show we
work with that Annette folks and
sometimes it's great and sometimes I'm
in the chair Monday through Thursday 10
a.m Eastern check us out on Rumble
podcast mug Club if you're not a
subscriber you do get this mug that is
other things that I have said earlier by
the way hit the like button and show we
got a lot of feedback too with you
hosting both you and Dave you both do a
great job you know eventually I want to
get to the point where we can help build
some other shows here yeah and uh show
Gerald yeah show Gerald you love them I
love it we have a lot of wonky stuff
today so I was like ah this is probably
a Gerald day it feels good yeah I like
you do I like covering some of the wonky
stuff yeah it's a good time I like
making fun of San Francisco by the way I
used to love San Francisco I would
travel there to go to Wine Country I'd
always fly into the airport SFO get
there at about nine o'clock in the
morning go up to a couple of different
spots grab some sandwiches or something
go and sit and look at the Golden Gate
Bridge and now just be dead by that
point I would be dead because somebody
would have killed me at several of those
stops well now thanks to Pfizer
thousands have left their Heart in San
Francisco also I don't like sitting on
toilets of feces right you know pillows
pillows of poop throughout the lawn you
just kind of pick your own pillow people
are worse than animals like animals use
the corner they do yeah these people
just do it everywhere and by these
people I mean San franciscans San
Francisco anyone of all Stripes correct
colors yes we do not uh discriminate
here dogs also don't shoot up into their
last remaining vein in their paw inside
of the bathrooms right
yeah you know when like natural
disasters are about to happen the
animals are the first to alert us they
should have known with everything
leaving San Francisco that it was about
to go down but speaking of I can't say
speaking of going down because you'll
take that the wrong way anyway Ted Cruz
was on The View on Monday you can uh and
you can't speak when you do that
I had to change uh directions there a
little bit be awfully busy
we'll just want to have somebody on that
they disagree with so that they can yell
at them and as is typically the case
Anna Navarro lets us know that she was a
republican Republican and uh it went
just about like you would expect it to
go I read the chapter to someone who
agreed with you most of your career how
do you reconcile your constitutional
convictions with what happened on
January 6 and trying to overturn the
election when 60 court cases got knocked
down there are a lot of folks in the
media that try to anytime a republican
is in front of a TV Camera try to say
the election was fair and square and
legitimate you know who y'all don't do
that to you don't do it to Hillary
Clinton who stood up and said Trump
stole the elections
who said who said that the election was
stolen they sat here
okay so it's illegitimately Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win please tell us
fat photo negative of Diane Keaton
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities across this country
[Music]
is the left doesn't engage in violence
really you said really Hillary Clinton
didn't say whatever she didn't say I'm
saying to you listen
and she said we stand here and you were
fine with her saying it was illegitimate
yes she called Donald Trump the next
morning and she conceded the election
results Trump is an illegitimate
president Hillary Clinton says the
election is stolen from you Hillary
Clinton in 2002 George W Bush was
selected Not Elected oh somebody came
prepared to take on their idiotic
arguments yeah I think he did a pretty
good job actually then Navarro's like
listen I know you came here to yell and
sell your book but we're not going to do
that it's like oh gosh just please just
like push her down she called him the
next morning yes but she spent the last
however many years going everywhere that
would take her and say that he was not
elected legitimately right so six years
plus going also she should have done it
that night and so yeah she locked
herself inside so the fact that they're
acting like she had Integrity about it
is exactly nonsense she didn't even go
out and give her concession speech no no
the interns were crying and we were kind
of laughing about all of this I remember
doing a live stream and I'm like I don't
normally laugh at somebody else's
Misfortune but in this case I'm
absolutely making an exception because
you guys thought this was a coronation
and it wasn't make sure you hit the like
button like Steven said just a minute
ago hit the like button if you are
having a good time with us it also
pisses off YouTube and it for no other
reason than that do you need more you
know what though he made a mistake he
said antifa riots he did BLM when we did
the yeah the change in my mind we did
antifa as a domestic terrorist
organization I said you know what no I'm
not with black lives matter because
people know that they'll recognize it
and you can make the case anyway it's
not yeah absolutely it's not which
points can you make it's making the
strongest point and letting it sit
because Whoopi Goldberg can't handle it
you heard her she's like well when when
you said when I said something about how
that was something and then but what I'm
saying is you're not you're [ __ ]
she's well the the argument though
always going to go back to him on Race
though so you say BLM it gives her an
immediate trump card for that entire
Studio I think that's why he went with
antique well no I I but I agree but I
would say please I'll play three or four
moves down the road please come back at
me with BLM being a legitimate
organization Oh you mean BLM that's
founder bought houses with the money
instead of actually using it to help out
the cause that she was supposed to be
representing like I would have just been
ready to pack that right in the face
yeah all the founders but yes
yeah well look they had a lot of money
they're not gonna have the black lives
matter subdivision yeah exactly yeah
well the left is always uh going to
argue that Ted Cruz is wrong in bringing
up the riots that because they had
nothing to do with the elections right
right of course the antivirus had
nothing to do with the elections
rioting burning cities down threatening
political retribution having politicians
threaten people and say they shouldn't
be out of the streets that's not in any
way shape or form trying to impact
future elections or current people in
the White House oh yeah that's right
they actually did protest outside of the
White House and uh they were doing stuff
that looked very very similar to January
6. Watch the end of this clip
is full enough so far yeah I'm just
gonna you know I'm gonna have oh whoops
oh boy remember the barricades that were
torn down at the Capitol boy that you
mean that were open well in some cases
torn down but mostly opened yes that's
true
that seems pretty similar
oh they're they're going to keep that as
a souvenir
well they just don't like the fence yes
or the church they burn down right they
are anti-fences that you're they that
depends
over there Dave it's a black fence yeah
well what are you saying about these
guys that's why they they don't think it
should be there it should be a white
fence were they listening to Stained or
puddle of Mud what did I hear there I
think that was rage oh okay yeah yeah
Killing In The Name of you can pick that
album up at Walmart's next to one of
their shirts yes yeah there's a
non-explicit version available too yeah
oh so it's mostly bleeps yes yeah that's
fantastic it's hard to kind of keep the
rhythm going to the Man by completely
selling yourself out yes yes it's you
you have lived long enough to become
that which you hate and sell the men
selling Hitler light t-shirts yes yeah
well that's true no it's absolutely true
that's why we have the chege of air
thing you know and by the way the
socialism is for fake shirts of course
we can't sell but yeah this is only in
one place in live shows but socialism is
for Dunces it's people say Well that's
incendiary do you know what Che Guevara
did he was like Hitler minus what some
people would consider the charm and that
and I don't mean Hitler was Charming or
he was right I mean he was able to
convince enough people and Che Guevara
wasn't so he was just more violent and
they found him like a [ __ ] in Bolivia
with an entirely loaded gun that had
never been fired saying I'm worth more
to you alive than dead and I'm pretty
sure they killed him anyway well that's
that's a fair point that's good yes yeah
whenever he a guy like that gets taken
out I I don't celebrate we talked about
this I do but I am a little happy yeah
well he said he he was incredibly racist
too he hated black people he hated black
people because there were a lot of black
people in Cuba right a lot of black
people who speak who speak Spanish and
he wanted pure blood European Spanish
Europeans and he executed and he went
before the U.N and said execute without
trial absolutely we will continue to
execute without trial and he bragged
about it and a huge portion of them were
black people that's something people
don't want to acknowledge and not to
mention gay people no yeah they never
want to acknowledge that in fact they
were celebrating I think his birthday
was like his dad his death day right
we can be careful we'll get in trouble
on YouTube for for being somewhat happy
when I say somewhat because I don't
Revel like you know God takes no
pleasure in the death of the wicked
that's what I mean not that this person
wasn't evil and didn't deserve to die he
did he was right but just saying that so
nobody clips that but I take it pleasure
yes will you take pleasure in a lot of
different ways any hole will do
typically
Watering Hole watering typical mortum
pleasure Dave which is something you
should seek counseling about look they
don't fight it yeah Rigamortis makes it
easy it does all right well look we
talked uh just a scratching trying to
move on
um they're like yes
whatever you want I think Gerald yeah
this is not a fair name with both of us
it really is it's actually kind of fun
for me because it kind of unleashes the
comedy and both of you neither one of
you have to come back to the point at
all you're just like well let's just
keep going it's funny don't worry too
chat chat says you're killing it oh well
thank you all of the monetary uh
promises that I made to you will be paid
quickly in ethereum so I'd cash it out
quickly yeah unless you didn't read the
other four yeah
Gerald Dave's like wow executing without
trying yeah looking at that positive bro
all right so midterms are coming up we
said off the top that we were going to
give you some information that you
needed obviously a lot of people are
talking about it it's in the news right
now we had Ron DeSantis debating last
night I think we have Dr Oz division
getting tonight Herschel Walker debates
every single night but normally with
himself
it's very unfortunate I like the guy I
want him to win because he's a
republican but he's got some problems
and we're going to talk about some of
these candidates aren't necessarily the
strongest people that we would say we
would want to have but when it comes
down to choosing between a republican
even though a flawed candidate and a
Democrat who is going to push policies
that the left loves like abortion up to
and including birth sometimes you got to
hold your nose and pull the lever for
the Republican because at least they
believe in your right to Freedom okay so
they're right around the corner and the
Democrats are I think because every
single show is talking about this and
everyone is panicking I think they're
getting a little nervous
how about this this is a New York Times
poll brand new here asking voters what's
the top issue on your mind this election
inflation together that is 40. close to
half of all respondents saying that's
their top issue nothing else even cracks
10 right now and we've abortions five
percent when it comes to the economy of
inflation state of democracy yeah and
typically this has been a pretty good
indicator of weird things
this is the average of the generic
ballot right now and you can see the
Republicans with a lead here that is a
2.2 point lead for Republicans now as
close generally speaking but we were
here a week ago taking you through the
generic ballot in a week ago this number
was inside of one point you had that
inflation news over the last week
certainly didn't help the Democrats and
it does seem that as the economy moves
to Center Stage Republicans are
improving their chances here so I'm one
thing that I'm very happy about is that
the Democrats have failed to make
abortion the top priority like we saw so
one of our concerns we wanted Roe v Wade
to be overturned we thought it should go
back to the States and we thought more
reasonable rules and regulations for
abortion pretty much getting rid of it
in most cases was what was necessary but
we also knew that we may take a hit in
the elections because of it so I'm glad
to see that I'm also terrified to see
that eight percent so if democracy
really is a problem the state of
democracy what the state of democracy I
want more than eight percent yeah except
people caring about it they're like well
heck if as long as I can go buy stuff
cheap and I have a good job I really
don't care where I live yeah the state
of the Republic was actually like it's
its demise was imminent yes I hope it's
more than eight percent
eight percent of you guys care about
this I just don't understand why we just
watched some nerdy guy make Madden
circles about abortions
back to the Forefront when did it go
it go away always the economy stupid
look what we got here I rolled up my
sleeves 2.2 percent that's the
difference there it's like what are you
yeah I'm a working man just like one of
you guys look I wear Vans with khakis
it's like those are Payless airwalks
but not the same but when they went out
of business I stole 200 pairs
okay well look uh inflation is really
bad they're like well the inflation news
I'm like it wasn't the inflation news
last week you [ __ ] it's been the
inflation news for the last several
months okay and Nancy Pelosi thinks that
inflation really isn't a problem and
that all we need to do is change the
subject oh and the fact is is that uh
when I hear people talk about inflation
as I heard them there we have to change
that subject inflation is a global
phenomena phenomenon it's what that's
the EU the European Union the UK the
British have higher the inflation rate
than we do here it's not really the
fight is not about inflation it's about
the cost of living
is that not deflation
[ __ ] you know I'm not a math Asian but
uh I thought that inflation could impact
the cost of living ah is that not is
that no longer true correlation doesn't
equal causation but in this case
absolutely okay yeah absolutely okay
I'll put her dentures in her high ball
she's just sitting there I taste gimlets
yeah fix a dent and forget the UK that
she started to say words that didn't
require her mouth to separate too much
at that point she was like okay I'm
British she's running low on blood of
the innocent but it's a really lazy
argument
Europe always has higher inflation rates
than the us so you can compare it now
but that ignores that they always do I
was raised in Quebec where gas was often
too it's more similar to Europe in a lot
of ways yeah if we were buying
Electronics I remember as a kid an N64
game would be 69.99 that's much more
expensive yeah gas would be two times
the price I mean food was way more
expensive sales tax was 14 it was
actually 15 sorry when I was being
raised so it really is a weak argument
but I have heard from a lot of people
saying well how do we debunk this it's
always higher in Europe yeah and they've
both gone up yeah those are the easy
things to debunk and you can say right
now too well it's interesting that you
chose to go with European union and you
chose Britain and you chose the UK
Japan right now so if we focus on kind
of these East Asian democracies Japan
has three percent Taiwan 2.75 South
Korea 5.6 so it's not the entire world
Nancy and Joe and Kamala that's having a
problem with this and by the way
this isn't the easiest argument to make
to win this argument it's lazy in that
it's saying well it's bad everywhere
it's not our fault no your policies are
contributing to this maybe inflation
would be a little bit higher right now
right maybe supply chain things maybe
that is possible I'll grant you that for
the sake of argument I'm not agreeing
I'm not saying it is but just for the
sake of argument you're telling me that
your energy policies have helped curb
inflation by making gas prices Higher by
making oil go up in price by not tapping
into natural resources that we currently
have here you're telling me right now
that it's okay to just throw more money
on the fire to solve inflation isn't
that typically what leads to more
inflation is government spending we're
forgetting something else what's that
printing more money we can just keep
printing more and that won't lead to
inflation no no no because you'll have
more of it exactly you can just you just
keep doing that yes yes why tax any
what are we even doing here just make it
can we get this printer ourselves you
make more money than you take it all
back yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
I believe this is brilliant I think
we've done our jobs here you know we're
just getting off the show right now I'm
kidding yourself to Christmas just just
make more money all right have we have
we thoroughly taken care of that for you
if anybody says inflation is high
everywhere you understand that in Europe
it is almost always if not always in the
Canada in the Canada did I just do that
that's fine in the Canadian areas that
are north of here that for some reason
we don't own they always have higher
prices as well and currently in other
places and democracies around the world
they don't suck and they're facing
what was that what
and they're facing Wars by the way Japan
right now I don't know if you've seen
their building I'm sure uh gingersnap
knows this they're it's the biggest
building up of an Arsenal um really
since World War II well North Korea is
flexing their muscle right now China's
flexing their muscle with Taiwan and
Japan is basically like okay we hope
everybody comes to our Aid because if
this happens especially on both fronts
this is going to be a major problem if
we keep shooting nukes into the water
though we're gonna make some monsters
yeah that's how we're going I think
that's what we do to get rid of them no
haven't you seen project Monarch I know
but that's just nonsense that's
Hollywood stuff yeah but I think it's
real it's the nukes that are gonna make
it like it well Japan needs some help so
we should send them when we should send
them Public School teachers
yeah all right so yeah when a killer
whale is living in your house
arguing over the clicker
I like killer whales they're pretty fun
yeah they are all right yeah you got
hands I'm not wrong
of course Dave not if they have hands
fine I'll never get the remote back
that's a fair point yeah
thinking of taking stuff back a lot of
States seemed like they were Out Of
Reach even in 2020
um and they're not suddenly not so
unattainable and there's a bunch of
states that we're doing very well and
obviously Florida is typically a
Republican state which is fantastic for
us it's usually a pretty good stronghold
the home of current governor Ron
DeSantis uh crushing his opponent by the
way Charlie crisp by double digits also
the number of registered Republicans a
percentage of Voters it's up several
hundred thousand people in Florida
Florida yeah it's a very Stark Trend
absolutely he's handled the school stuff
well he's handled covet very well he
probably even more than Texas had uh
policies that benefited local business
kept everybody safe schools by the way
he had some information on schools I
think it's in the clip that we're going
to play here he also disciplined Chris's
dog in front of him he did well he was a
bad boy and he put his nose in it and
used a newspaper it was necessary after
the debate though on Monday night last
night it's pretty easy to see why he's
winning yeah you're the only governor in
the history of Florida did this ever
shut down our school tools you're the
only governor in the history of Florida
to shut down our business I never did
that as Governor did you have a global
pandemic that you were dealing with
Charlie we need to have somebody who is
something that understands it's
important to listen to science to do
what's right utilize common sense you
don't just shut down at the outset and
then when it's you know politically
convenient for you you want to open back
up the store political Point somebody
packed the audience
[Applause]
well so he opposed having kids in school
his supporters sued me to keep the kids
out of school in 2020. and how and how
critical was that decision we just got
the nation's report card the results
from all 50s sport on number three in
fourth grade reading and number four in
the country in fourth grade math and if
you adjust that for demographic we are
number one in the country it did not
have happened if we let Charlie Chris
and his friends lock our kids out of
school like they did in California and
like they did in New York boom that's
how you do it right there you go
straight to the numbers and say our
policies resulted in better outcomes for
who your children I would have added one
thing I would when you started just say
is anybody buying this is anybody buying
that the Democrat wanted more that's a
little bit more of Donald Trump but you
should just say that is anyone actually
buying this that's what they try is
anyone actually sitting yeah
yeah he was the shutdown guy was
DeSantis no you were criticizing him
when you were you were gearing up for
your run to say he didn't shut down
enough yeah it's really a lazy argument
for them to say well you know I wasn't
in power and uh he shut them down and by
the way a lot of people shut down for
two weeks we didn't we did the mug Club
quarantine month but we understood we
said hey I understand why some
businesses because we didn't we didn't
know after about two weeks it was clear
it was very clear after just a few weeks
and so that's what he said you closed
down at the outset he goes you should
have trusted the science you mean when
he had doctors from some of the most
well-respected institutions in the world
and he was kicked off of YouTube when he
was talking to them and letting his
constituents hear the conversation you
mean that kind of trust the science I
don't really buy your argument Chris is
basically throwing Haymakers at this
point trying to see if he can get
something going but he also
he wrecked him on just about every
single point and you will see some other
clips that the media is trying to
portray as DeSantis getting owned by
Chris it's a very very big stretch but
he kicked his butt on the issue of
transitioning kids you're a 15 year old
you can't go get a tattoo in the state
of Florida yet we're saying you could
get a double mastectomy of course not it
is inappropriate to do this for minors
and in Florida we are not going to allow
that to happen boom boom easy enough you
can't go at 15. he chose 15. I would
have gone 12. yes 12 and a 10 11 that
sounds a little bit worse but that's
actually what's happening and it's it's
a middle point they want five-year-olds
right to be able to have some of these
things start to take place changing your
pronouns which we just heard from the
NIH is a really bad thing to do right a
five-year-old I think it was the NHS
sorry yeah yeah I get the uh the the the
letters yeah numbers I'm fine with
letters it's silly bad with letters
that's fair
um
one thing that I did see though that I
wanted our researchers to pull and they
did was this clip has been going around
mostly from NBC News because he was
Chris was asking DeSantis if he was
going to stick around for all four years
and I just want to say something at the
outset of this that is one of the most
insane questions that I've ever heard
because Chris I guarantee right now if
somebody came to you and said Hey Joe
Biden's not gonna run would you like to
be the Democratic nominee for president
of the United States and you were still
in this race you'd be like heck yeah
baby just sign me up it'd be a crisp
shaped hole in the wall of course more
power and something that I can't
possibly do a good job with I'm your man
right so here's the NBC news clip and
how they're portraying Ron desantis's
answer and let me remind the viewers he
wouldn't even answer you if he would
stay four years if you re-elect him as
your Governor you're running for
governor you're asking them to vote for
you for governor at a minimum you ought
to be able to tell them if you get
reelected you'll serve as governor Ron
Governor so we had the Border that was
in much better shape in January of 2021
he pivots right and so they're like oh
see he won't even answer the question if
he's going to stay and run it doesn't
matter but here here's the full context
of the answer he gave earlier in the
debate and I have a question for you
you're running for governor why don't
you look in the eyes of the people of
State of Florida and say to them if
you're re-elected you will serve a full
four-year term as Governor yes or no
yes or no Ron will you serve a full
four-year term if you're re-elected
governor of Florida
it's not a tough question
it's a fair question he won't tell you
we did not agree on the candidates
asking each other my son's Governor it's
your turn well listen I know that
Charlie's interested in talking about
2024 and Joe Biden but I just want to
make things very very clear the only
worn out old donkey I'm looking to put
out the pasture is Charlie Chris
in political terms them's fighting words
listen he was just being polite he was
saying is it my time he waited for that
but every single clip that you saw in
the media cut when he was standing there
right and not answering in an awkward
silence kind of moment and by the way
just in case you thought Charlie curse
was actually serious and genuine in
saying that you should stay for the full
term of Governor when you're elected he
ran for the Senate while he was governor
in 2009 so that would have been a very
helpful piece and that's because he
believed he was going to lose by the way
yeah exactly he's like I need to find my
next gig so that I don't get out of
government work it's like being down in
the scorecard so you foul your opponents
you're like I would have won for this
damn ref man that's true that's what I
do it very beginning I kick them in the
nuts and get disqualified so I don't get
punched in the face he's the beta
O'Rourke of uh he is yeah
I need another race to lose
where can I go next I hope I lose it I
hope I lose it I think it's good that he
didn't answer his question no I think it
was too he pivoted to issues that people
care about he didn't need to jump down
there with him because of course that
was just going to be distraction from
what he really wanted to talk about and
this is something moderator pointed it
out yes and this is something too that I
think a lot of people the go-to-party
system and you really are you do have to
understand it especially in a place like
Florida you are voting the platform it
does oh yeah matter now neither platform
is perfect but you don't want a
parliamentary system for example like in
Canada where you can win the Prime
Minister office a prime minister's
office with only 30 something percent of
the vote and the platform right now is
Chris versus Ron DeSantis the platform
of abortion up until including birth
period the platform of locking
everything down the platform of
increased taxes right the platform of
civil unrest uh versus DeSantis and
people if they're electing him look if
he's called up to run for president
people are electing his judgment and he
will decide who will be filling filling
in his spot no I think look I think it's
a good point I don't know how it works
in Florida through lieutenant governor
becomes governor if they have a special
election or anything I have no idea
Florida I'm sorry I don't know your ways
but it's important to understand that
Ron DeSantis is a presidential candidate
obviously he's one of the Front Runners
to be able to take that position if he
chooses to he hasn't declared for that
yet so it's irrelevant right now he's
running for governor and he's doing a
damn good job and he's kicking your butt
Charlie so maybe focus on your own
election and worry about where he's
going to go next you sir are going to
one of the many many retirement homes
that your state houses if you want to
hit the like button if that's what you
would like to see for Charlie Crist and
make sure it's
we need like a more man I'd like it but
it needs to be like the it's more manly
a little bit more of a smash yeah I
think kind of thing but it's fun
um let's go to one of the other races
that we are excited about in Arizona
with uh our very own Kerry Lake
um
there's a good reason Stephen make sure
you keep your legs crossed
um Carrie Lake uh actually that traffic
keeper on there and push down that's
right buddy you know the game would you
like some duct tape or something a
binder hit it with a ruler
that only makes it worse
it gets angry
um 538 now gives Carrie like a 58 chance
to win against her Democratic opponent
Katie Hobbs that's up from 38 just a
month ago she's actually inside the
margin now take it takes I think it's
like a 1.8 percent uh leader 1.8 point
lead I should say not percent remember
the bumper stickers in 2016 trust Nate
silver 538 now they don't like him
anymore on the left they're like oh he's
too moderate he's just a chill it's like
you guys had so many bumper the bumper
sticker trust Nate silver I remember it
everywhere yeah well her
it's not just that it's just when it's
convenient right right it's not trust
Nate silver because Nate silver is
trustworthy it's trust Nate silver
because right now he's saying what we
like right right in the mainstream media
normally carries the water for people
but not right now
Carrie Lake's opponent Hobbes has even
faced criticism from them
they're not going to look at their
ballots well she just came and said that
God didn't debate her opponent she just
came and sat down with me and and
answered my questions for for a lot of
minutes a lot of minutes yeah a lot more
than one answer questions
and they're saying you know an open-toed
strong decision President Biden's former
2020 co-chair said I would debate and I
would want the people of Arizona to know
what my platform is if you think she's
as dangerous as you're saying to
democracy is it your responsibility as a
candidate who wants to run Arizona to
show and explain who their alternative
is
that is exactly what I'm doing right now
and there is a lot more ability to have
a conversation with you without her
interruptions and shouting uh to do that
um I thought that when I came on this
network that you were going to support
me and say that everything that I did
was fantastic but you're asking me tough
questions and I don't think I can handle
that no no no that's why I think being
Meek is the best way to run a campaign
yes yes especially when combined with my
abnormally small mouth
painting cycle and look I don't know a
whole lot about her other than she's
Democrat which is basically all that I
need to know about her when she's
running for governor in Arizona but I
like Carrie Lake I like what I've seen
from Carrie Lake but I specifically love
this from Carrie Lake because she's
pointing out the media's hypocrisy about
the election I thought you're gonna say
figure here's 150 examples of Democrats
denying election results
oh wow look at this this is from oh wow
like she's surprised Joe Biden's press
secretary reminder Brian Kemp stole the
gubernatorial election from Georgians
and Stacy Abrams Democrats saying that
is that an election denier
oh look at this
just heard Republican Ryan Costello said
it would be difficult for Stacy Abrams
to win because she lost her State bid
but yet she's still claiming she never
lost
Trump is an illegitimate president is
she an election denier she were a
president she'd be Abraham Lincoln
that's fair and Justin Bieber like her
husband
lovely great but she is a very fetching
candidate and we respectfully think
she's attractive yes yes absolutely and
she's also doing a fantastic I will say
this Carrie
I know your your kids her kids watch I
think right yes okay so your kids are
watching right now I know that you are
already planning to do that but when I
told you in the interview make sure you
point out that I'm just going to take
like
.0001 credit for that because that is
what I've been waiting for somebody to
just come out and be like Oh election
deniers we talked about what was it kill
chain was the the movie on uh
documentary on HBO in 2018 I believe
with all of the democratic people saying
that with Hillary Clinton denying the
election that Ted Cruz points
specifically said that Dominion voting
machines are easily hackable and showed
it live yes
didn't win the election because Dominion
voting machines could have been hacked
that's their argument and right now we
may actually have it down here so I
don't want to hit it but they're doing
it again Democrats are actually kind of
seeding the ground a little bit telling
you that this is going to be a problem
but look it's not just that Kerry lake
is doing well in the polls it's not just
that she is doing a fantastic job
destroying the lies of the left
the enthusiasm Gap right now is
something that is massive right and so
just take a look when when you guys were
introduced at the show for Stephen and
Dave when you guys were in was it
Phoenix Arizona yeah just look at the
audience reaction to them with Terry
Lake I think here future governor
that's reaction to Carrie yeah
I could have just gone home
it's done it seems they liked her yeah
yeah it was a sustained Applause and
Kerry Lake had the balls to come out to
a comedy show yeah I know knowing that
that was probably going to be used
against her oh sorry Stephen no when I
we went to Phoenix I don't know if Dave
said this I was in the hotel room
watching uh Watching Casino for like the
15th time because it was an AMC and uh I
saw attack ads against Kerry Lake and I
was in them he was in them are you
serious I said like something about the
FB like defunding the FBI said well yeah
I do think we have a problem with our
intelligence communities and the attack
ads said Kerry Lake serious or seriously
dangerous and I was like oh my God
there may be a lot of them by now the
specifically the one with the FBI and
Kerry like and look I know Carrie is
doing a fantastic job but she's also
helping people down ballot as well
especially in her state right so you've
got Blake Masters who has surged
recently in the polls against Democrat
Mark Kelly
um they're doing a fantastic job with
undecided voters older voters and women
they've all moved towards Masters in the
recent days and again it's no wonder
when you have somebody like that at the
top of the ticket for your state just
kind of electrifying the base a little
bit but look at the groups undecided
voters right now independent voters that
is the group that Republicans are doing
incredibly well we didn't talk about
that when we looked at the polling with
what people were thinking right now
those voters are going overwhelmingly it
seems right now towards Republicans so
if we can keep that momentum
particularly with strong candidates that
you need to be a a Meek or a week really
flat out week moderate candidate it's
people like to carry Lakes it's people
who are actually willing they push
button stand for their convictions I
mean and I will say this with Kayla we
spend some time with her there in
Phoenix like Carrie like when people say
oh she was a Democrat she was incredibly
anti-war and we were dealing with in the
wake of George W bush
um and she said why yeah and she still
is and she's answered for it but she is
genuine having spent time with and by
the way a fantastic family and even
people surrounding her she's a blueprint
for a lot of people out there as to how
you win an election yeah don't back down
doesn't mean you have to be bombastic
doesn't mean that you're undisciplined
she's disciplined but she's also uh raw
in in the best of ways yeah she's very
honest right and it's easy to just be
honest and go out and speak to the media
but she has good media skills as well oh
yeah which is I mean obviously I mean
this is obvious it's incredibly
important to have in this day and age
but Donald Trump had that too Donald
Trump was so at ease with the media and
just kind of pushing their lies and if
he didn't know how to do that he would
just make fun of them which was also fun
you know why don't think about it Donald
Trump worked in the media in
entertainment yeah same thing with
Carrie Lake right she was a reporter a
lot of conservatives because they're
rejected by media and entertainment they
don't get that kind of experience yeah
so these are examples of people who do
and you see when they know how to
prepare when they know the arguments
from the left from people in the media
but I repeat myself before they're made
they're able to be effective it is a
blueprint on how the Republican party
needs to move forward it's strong
conservatives who stand by their
convictions and will speak directly to
the people yeah absolutely that skill
alone is what took him from being kind
of a Joe candidate to becoming the
president yeah I made fun of him at
skills not so yeah not just him I made
fun of his candidacy I didn't think it
was legitimate nope I was like I didn't
think he was serious I thought it was
just a publicity stunt and I made fun of
that not him necessarily but I was like
there's no way I even told you I was
like he'll be gone by October I mean in
September I don't even remember when we
were talking about it I think that's
gone and you were like no no no he's in
it for the long run but apparently every
election has been legitimate except for
his just right just uh just that one no
you've got it to me yeah see seems to be
the point let me send let me put a finer
point on it every election the Democrats
win
he's legitimate that's legit yes every
election that they don't or every
election that they think they might not
will be preemptively called illegitimate
that's right just to make sure just to
cover all the bases we should change the
term from put a finer point on it to put
a carry Lake Point on it here even if
it's uh fine
I think her husband is now getting on a
plane
uh all right so during the debate
Masters uh was asked if Biden was a
legitimate president and like we said
being direct being ready to go having a
little bit of media training goes a long
way check out his response is Joe Biden
the legitimately elected president of
the United States Joe Biden's absolutely
the president I mean my gosh have you
seen the gas prices lately legitimately
I'm not trying to trick you he's duly
sworn and certified he's the legitimate
president he's in the White House and
unfortunately for all of us I'm not
trying to trick you and by the way it's
bad news yeah not a joke it's pretty
good why did they have two signers by
the way
you see that there were two signers
there for for Sean was it one was was it
for crosstalk maybe like where the
moderator was talking in the small
picture yeah in the gas prices lately
legitimately oh it is okay he's duly
sworn and certified he's the legitimate
president he's in the White House and
unfortunately for all of us did she just
wave was that like hi Mom yeah
somebody's signing in Spanish are they
really I don't know oh okay that was a
good answer I would have run with that
and been like well yes thank you that
sounds very good yes it is Arizona they
do have a large Hispanic population that
makes sense yeah there's uh no Integrity
anymore so they have to have several
signs for everybody interrupting each
other yes do the signers actually get
into a fight if there's like a heated
discussion because you can only
communicate that they're actually
fighting with words if you yeah
one of the signers gets a folding chair
yeah this turns into the WWE yeah the
refs looking away
exactly well look in Georgia we we
understand the the race here you're
going to want to look away from this
person Stacy Abrams who's the president
of Earth by the way that is the the
highest honor I think we should call her
Madame Earth president which president
said of dirt yes yes
I don't think that's true so in the
person that she still thinks is the
illegitimate governor of Georgia is
kicking the crap out of her Brian Kemp
crushing her by 7.5 points in the RCP
polling
um Abrams is actually already already
preemptively because she knows
refusing to concede her inevitable loss
you refuse to concede and say that you
lost do you stand by that decision today
absolutely the election was not fair the
process was not fair uh you know what
I'm actually I'm sorry that uh that
doesn't seem right Gerald the label
clearly says 2019.
you know what guys look that's my bad I
don't get to sit in this chair that
often sometimes I make mistakes that was
that was when she didn't concede the
election that she lost in 2018 and still
has not conceded that election to this
day right never
um hit make sure guys hit the like
button again it helps us out we love it
and you you know you like hearing and
comment below other examples because
we're going by the ones off of the top
of our head I'm sure there are other
examples of that oh there's plenty or
example well but so she's got a new well
it's kind of a new old trick that she's
pulling um she's saying that uh a
republican by God is racist I've never
heard that argument before but it's a
new one that the left is using against
Republicans and that he has racist
policies that are meant to keep her
voters uh from being able to vote and
that that he's suppressing all of the
voters that would absolutely turn out
and make her win
and it's unfair what he's doing it's
terrible the current governor said it in
his primary debate he said that the
election was free and fair he also said
he was frustrated by the results and
that's what led him to pass laws to make
it more difficult to vote absentee made
it more difficult to use drop boxes for
people who have on-call schedules for
folks who can't get somewhere from nine
to five they now have a much more
difficult time 1.9 million Georgians
will be affected he said that that's why
he cut off funding he won't allow the
County elections officials to seek
outside money to shore up the lack of
money they receive from the state that's
why he made it illegal for people to get
water and food and lines in the state of
Georgia have been up to eight hours long
oh my gosh okay first off do we we
covered this I'm sorry every time it
happens I don't want to get distracted
by it but yes you can get food yes you
can get water you just can't get vote
for Stacy Abrams water handed out in
line it's called electioneering you're
not supposed to do it and so that's what
they were making sure it didn't happen
corn syrup
you want to hand out Funyuns that's on
you that's fine right but in Georgia
this year we have Donuts
is this the licked Donuts why is this
water so why is it so viscous from
precious's understudy why are you here
broke the record for first day early
vote this year and that's twice what
they say in 2018 so if Kemp is trying to
suppress the votes doing a very bad job
at it and I can't do something else you
can hand up you lose in fact I'll take
one if you've got it it's not chocolate
milk it's not soda it's something in
between I put liquor in it yeah was that
not a real offer I was that sounded
fantastic I know I wish I had you who
knows I've never had a Yoo-hoo ever
really we didn't have it in Canada well
that's why Canada I need to try it is it
good no I mean it's okay
it's as a kid yes it's fantastic
it's a ghetto chocolate milk it really
is yes when you when you grow up it's
called the Kahlua
yeah mama wants some more of her you who
all right look I can't drive you who to
school
that's a really bad idea moms don't
drink and drive your kids to school it's
okay at most it gets mostly absorbed
yeah oh it takes me a lot to be legally
over the limits yes uh it's just a
mimosa in the morning uh look Camp
actually addressed the claims of voter
suppression in his debate with Abrams
and uh didn't go well for Abrams uh the
Miss Abrams is going to do a lot of
attacking of my record tonight because
she doesn't want to talk about her own
record on 2018 in the governor's race we
had the largest African-American turnout
in the country she said that Senate Bill
202 our recent elections Integrity act
what we passed two years ago would be
suppressive in Jim Crow 2.0 just this
past May in our primaries we again had
record turnout in the Republican primary
and the Democratic Primary in Georgia
it's easy to vote and hard to cheat
there you go that's how you do it by the
way she had rested defeating face yes
she did yes yes
she was just in a defeated pose yeah
inside her head she's going oh [ __ ] oh I
I will say this though at what point you
know Democrats would always say oh if we
increase turnout we win right well this
is obviously the strategy right now for
Republicans increase or not there's a
lot more turnout what Democrats mean
what the left means is if we increase
turnout without any kind of verification
we win they mean people who aren't
citizens they mean people who maybe
aren't eligible to vote when you have a
legitimate voting process and I don't
think that identification is an
unreasonable qualification to vote
voting goes up and it's also because
there's value if something's just out
you can mail and vote whenever it gets
how I still have health insurance uh
mail that's on my office desk I think
it's from 2017. well I mean we get so
much stuff in the mail in the mail is so
easy to rely on to make sure things
actually get delivered on time right we
don't have any problems with stuff
getting lost in the mail they've done
study after study on mail-in voting and
they show that it actually under counts
the vote because there are so many that
are done either late they're done
inappropriately and so they're not
counted as votes or they're lost in the
mail one way or the other going to them
or actually coming back except in 2020
wherever every single vote counted
except for
um and look free and fair election guys
right the results in Georgia 100
110 the most inaccurate right it's the
most accurate we've ever seen except
when we actually called in to question
George's vote and they did a recount
they found more votes did you guys
remember that they found literally
thousands more votes that weren't
included in the original tally and
they're like this is really that's our
fault I'm so sorry about that there's so
much freeness and fairness I almost
can't even well sometimes you have to
bring in the votes later in a cooler yes
well camera equipment Dave that's what I
meant let's make sure that we're clear
on that free and fair elections include
camera equipment cameras have a right to
vote too and then voting brand camera
equipment that's true yes look in the
senate race Herschel Walker is actually
uh for all of his faults Herschel Walker
is actually statistically tied with
Warnock right and remember warnock's
Victory and Donald Trump did a lot to
make this happen I think he pushed so
hard that people kind of went Democrat
when maybe they wouldn't have his
victory in the a 2020 runoff election
was what ended up giving the Democrats
the Senate yeah and gave them the
opportunity to you know create hell all
around you throughout the country yeah
but we're doing our best to take it back
in Pennsylvania the latest Insider
Advantage poll has Dr Oz uh tied with
John fetterman and that's that's pretty
significant because he was down by 13
points how many [ __ ] can you fit in
a room that's true I'm not a fan of
doctor no no no no that was a screw up I
don't know who anybody I mean he's had
some he's also been on the wrong side of
transitioning you know young people too
like he's yeah it's you know you are
picking the lesser of two evils but you
are I don't I don't envy you guys no I I
don't at all and again this is one of
those odds like the TV show yes some
weird stuff going on there he's like
Welcome to Oz [ __ ] oh geez I'm making
some toilet Yoo-hoo
whether you want it or not I'm here to
make you a lady oh boy all right I think
you should get down on your knees I'll
start with you
ah it's just a skinhead rubbing him
though
speaking of skinheads his candidate I'm
just kidding no he's uh no I I don't
like him I I'm surprised that he's doing
as well as he is as unlikable as he is
but he's running against fetterman and
this guy I know he has some current
issues but he has terrible policies in
the past and that is what we're
attacking but he is talking
a little bit weird right now and has
some Joe bideness moments yeah a portion
right
s deserve to every
Street excuse me what state that you
live it's going to make a custom chopper
are so much better
than the
[Applause]
day going to make sure I don't push back
against
work to work
my name is
John
Fender woman
Dad hates you
I love how somebody out in the audience
said it's better woman in case you for a
fetterman in case you forgot you hear
like one person like just in case by the
way he had a stroke right yes
Joe Biden what's your excuse
[Music]
this guy's got a legitimate reason that
he might have some difficulty talking
and people just kind of Nod and go along
with him and I know you're going to get
some some more important winning
arguments because I will say this as
someone who said several people you know
in my my closer who have had Strokes uh
I I don't know that's a winning argument
to say he's unfit because of the stroke
because he could have largely uh you
know auditory processing issues I I
don't think he's completely out of it I
don't necessarily know from what I see
that he's brain damage I know that he
has a problem with that signaling from
his brain to his mouth but I've seen
people who are stroke victims who act
well yeah who've come back and I've also
seen people who weren't able to so if
you think it's a strong argument today
it could be taken off the table if he
recovers in a couple of months it's
relevant but it shouldn't be the main
argument exactly because when he isn't
having a problem getting his thoughts to
go to his brain to talk which I know is
a big issue they're bad his policies are
bad when they come out and make sense
that's the problem that we have right he
he advocated for eliminating cash bail
and also for releasing murder I think
he's also the guy who went and
vandalized what was it a was it a
restaurant or a store where he kicked
down the sign or something like that
he's he's a bit of a Loose Cannon and
maybe that plays well the guy with the
shaved head goatee and American Choppers
hoodie is a vandal what absolutely he
was upset over a meal is that what
happened I think he's going to bring out
your custom bike here in just a few
minutes
he's gonna leave his wife for Dita
vontes right well an unlikable Dr Oz
addressed fetterman this is come and
soak his record pretty well last week on
crime
the first step act had nothing to do
with convicted murderers being released
from prison especially after they've
been sentenced to life in prison it's a
whole different game so when John
Thunderman is asked if you could wave a
magic wand what's the one thing you
would do the one thing World Peace he
says well I'd get rid of life in prison
well I asked him that he actually said
it would be codifying Roe versus Wade
and abolishing the filibuster yeah well
the way I just described it in the past
as well and too often John fetterman
seems to pay more attention to the
feelings of the criminals than the
innocent who were hurt so he's changed
his mind is what you're saying so
basically whatever Direction the
political winds are blowing is what his
answer is going to be when you ask him
what is the one problem that you would
solve that's essentially what she just
said and by the way abolishing the
filibuster you think that's a good idea
you think codifying Roe v Wade is a good
idea against the wishes of people in
States across the country you think it's
okay to take that back even though the
Supreme Court says Nope we can't do it
this decision was inaccurate I don't
think that's a good idea and I think the
voters agree with me in places that you
would be surprised right of all of the
states other than maybe New York and
California of all of the states that you
think would be pretty solidly Democrat
and not turn this one is one of the
biggest surprises Oregon the news for
republicans in Oregon is fantastic and
Christine Drazen has a real shot to
become the next governor governor of
Oregon and I know a lot of us don't pay
attention to Oregon what do they have
like five electoral votes I mean maybe
maybe three now because people are
leaving well don't put them down
I don't know if she's a Carrie Lake why
wasn't Oz wearing scrubs yes how much if
I if I was a doctor yes exactly yeah I
would wear the white lab coat whether I
deserved it or not because put some
popsicle sticks in your pop you know
your your pocket square something
the you know yeah the heart thing the
stethoscope stethoscope thank you
hopefully Christine yeah you can walk up
to fetterman put it on his head go yeah
oh no one's home oh geez yeah just
Echoes that's all I hear so hopefully
Christine Drazen is going to become the
next governor of Oregon and for those of
you who don't care about Oregon politics
or don't know Oregon politics there
hasn't been a republican governor in 40
years I think a senator only in about
20. yeah senator in 20 years or state
senate sorry is this they I think I
don't know if it was a Senator Statewide
yeah it's been 20 years since anything
really significant for Republicans has
happened in Oregon and Oregon's policies
I don't remember exactly where Portland
is but uh yeah yeah it's in Oregon yeah
it's one of the crappy like when we
refer to cities the Democrat policies
have destroyed it San Francisco and
Portland not usually Seattle though
sometimes that happens for obvious
reasons right but Oregon is known like I
I just hired a guy from Oregon and I
can't say what his name is oh no um no
he's fantastic he's uh he's actually a
mixed martial art
this guy's fantastic he moved down from
Oregon and he's like you would not
believe it Lee no not Chad Lee
Dave in fact that was uh that was strike
three all right I gotta go yeah you
gotta go so uh really quickly well
here's something important they always
say you know the opposing party right
Surf Ninjas was that with Rob Schneider
yeah
um the opposing part of they say well
they always do well in midterms and
that's true right but if it's even
within Striking Distance in a place like
Oregon that is very atypical the story
here is this is first off in strong red
States they are getting even stronger
right Florida Texas yeah uh and then in
reliably blue States for the first time
in terms of 40 years they're looking at
becoming a red State the story here is
the rejection absolute all-out rejection
of what happened with kovid and the
Democrat policies I mean it's these
aren't anomalies this is a consistent
through line and these are live to votes
yes people lived through the policies of
these parties and they're voting against
it now we have other states and other
cities that need to do that around the
country with some of the water issues
we've seen in Jackson Mississippi I know
in Michigan and Flint having issues
there these are Democrat run strongholds
that they need to go oh your policies
suck and we end up paying the price
every single time for it somebody who
won't Nike founder Phil Knight he
donated a million dollars to Drazen
earlier this month and when he was
questioned how he could support an
anti-abortion candidate as the founder
of Nike he said Nike has good leadership
they make choices whatever they want but
I think I'm more conservative than Nike
okay that's fantastic they have good
leaders and they make choices you get to
make your own choices and Knight has
made another choice he's like look what
are the ways that I can help Republicans
win so support the Republican that
sounds pretty nice oh yeah I'm gonna
support the candidate who's independent
that will pull Democrat votes away so
he's given money to Betsy Johnson as
well just to make sure he's covered all
of his bases and who can blame him for
wanting to change when Oregon looks like
this
[Applause]
yeah that's just a nice little gift
heat stroke
[Music]
is she trying to help him or is she
robbing him yeah
it's a birthday party yes taking a dump
right here in front of everybody
that's a shock
God bless you man you know what it's
almost unbelievable that the store that
that person is taking a dump in has a
sign that says for lease in front of it
and there's not an actual business it's
because when Democrats rule these places
everybody who lives there suffers they
pay more in taxes they have fewer
protection from the police because crime
is rampant and the police no matter how
well funded you make them unless you
make them a military State cannot
possibly take care of every single
problem that these people create right
and it's no wonder that Kate Brown is
the least popular governor in the
country she's the incumbent that's
running governor in Oregon well we
should have invested in tents yeah we
really should we weren't like doing that
well for a while and now they're like
guys we're loaded I didn't know that you
could just live wherever you wanted that
guy who created that to throw up tent in
Congo he's making a killing oh my
goodness but you would if you want to
live in Portland you would also need the
laser guns as well
the Run and Jump Through the thing just
to test it for
I don't know where they are if they
still make them we should find some bad
but look we hope you guys have had fun I
hope this gives you some information on
how Republicans are doing and the
elections that are coming up get out and
vote if you live in these states if you
know anybody that lives in these states
get out and vote in those states make
sure you vote legally make sure you take
your ID even if they don't ask for it
just say hey I just want to make sure
you know that I am who I say I am and
here's my ID that I would need to rent
or to check out a library book down the
street but not to vote but I'm just
giving it to you just in case make sure
also that you share this show it's a lot
of fun we enjoy doing this get this
information out to all your friends and
uh I it's a good it's a it's a silver
lining like it is people want to go out
and you know Doom and Gloom all the time
right this what I'm hoping happens is
you look at for example the Cuban
Americans they're the most reliably
conservative voting block why because
many of them are first generation or
second generation they fled communism
socialism they lived it and they
rejected it right I'm hoping that
there's you know to a lesser degree the
equivalent here with kovid we all saw
you know the mask was off the Democratic
party and now you're seeing it even more
with transitioning children but I'm
hoping now that you have enough
Americans who say well we lived it boy
was that a mistake and I think we might
yeah absolutely I think you're right and
I think what we're seeing too and this
is the final point we'll go out on this
Hillary Clinton's now out there saying
that the elections are being stolen by
Republican Governors who are putting in
place because the Supreme Court is about
to rule on something saying that the
governors of the state or the state
legislatures if there's a problem with
their slate of electors they can handle
that at the state level they can remedy
that problem themselves before they send
the electors to
Washington to vote and she's saying that
that is stealing the election so Hillary
Clinton's out there saying that the
election is going to be stolen before we
actually have any elections and she's
talking about 2024 so she's just setting
the stage but nobody can trust the
election so maybe having all of these
laws that say we want to secure our
elections in these states is probably a
good idea but either way
YouTube piss off
[Music]